- [Harry] From John Wick to John Wayne,
gun fights in movies
can often look so real
that it's hard to imagine
how they're put together.
Here at the British Action Academy,
stuntman Andreas Petrides teaches students
how to safely perform firearm sequences.
[Andreas] Holding it, 10-point
check. One, two, three.
We do gun rush today,
which is the Firearms for Films course,
which teaches people
about the performance side
of using firearms on a film set.
My background, I've been a
stuntman for about 28 years now.
I've worked on many, many productions.
"Star Wars," I doubled Ewan McGregor
in all the lightsaber fights
and obviously trained Ewan.
On "Bond" films, I've done both.
I've trained the actors, and also
I've played characters myself,
and I've doubled characters.
- [Harry] In the old days, of course,
people used to actually get shot.
Nowadays, though, films use a
series of dummy replacements.
There are blanks, real working weapons
loaded with blank cartridges.
These are for when you just need
a big muzzle flash or a loud bang.
'Function' guns are replica
guns that don't actually fire.
Or for cheaper fake versions
that don't look as real in a close-up,
some movies use rubber guns.
The person responsible for these on a set?
The Weapons Master. And stunt performers
need to know exactly how to use them.
The thing with blanks is that
they do still make a lot of noise,
and you get the kind of flash as well
that you expect from a gunshot.
So it's a really realistic experience.
For actors, it's all about
selling the idea that it's a real gun.
Action!
[Participant] Bang bang.
Bang! Bang!
[Harry] And of course,
reacting to being shot is important.
[Harry] They teach you the
ways to kind of roll onto your
body so that you don't
just smack the floor,
but it does still kind of hurt.
These guys, they don't mess about.
One thing that can be very real
is the weight of the equipment
actors have to lug around.
According to Andreas, actors on the set
of "Saving Private Ryan" wore
packs weighted down with ammo,
all in the name of believability.
The prop guns themselves go
hand in hand with sound design.
When a gun fires, you're
hearing three acoustic elements:
the muzzle blast sound, the impact point,
and the crack sound of the
bullet traveling through the air.
Without this layering,
a movie just doesn't seem as realistic.
Cinema is filled with basic gun mistakes.
So how would a beginner
go about getting it right?
[Andreas] My advice to anybody
who wants to get into the
industry as a stunt performer
is, it's dedication.
You know, it's part of your life,
you gotta really want to do it.
It's not a part-time
hobby, and the more skills
you have under your belt,
the more employable you are.